When we think about truth
and justice and what that
actually means and what
we're actually exploring
in this show, it's not static.
What justice looks like to you will
not be what justice looks like to me.
I think we explore that
beautifully in season three.
Do you have a lead?
Maybe.
Can I come with?
I play Eva Pierre, a
high school principal
where a number of her
students are being trafficked.
Over the course of the
season layers are peeled back.
I need to do more.
The way I was able to get into the
character is I lived it, unfortunately.
I've had 30 years to intimately
understand sexual violence
against young black and brown girls.
Eva is trying to heal and make
amends and prove to herself
and the world that
she is a good person.
I found my moments of justice
and my version of the truth,
and I tried to give that to Eva.